Peter Shilton a very good day to you
what made him such a great goalkeeper
well first of all you know it's a very
sad day for me today with the Gordon
press in a way because he was my hero
and I was fortunate enough to watch him
when I was on the terraces at 10 years
of age sort of getting into the
Leicester team and I followed his career
until I actually signed for Leicester
myself and I had the opportunity to
watch him up close as a youngster but
also had about a year with him where we
trained together once a week and the
thing was about Gordon it was a
different era then as to what it is now
different rules for goalkeepers
goalkeepers tended to get challenged a
lot more physically but Gordon had this
a great knack have always been in the
right place at the right time you know
he he had a great positional sense and
he's I think his positioning was was
something that you know I always admired
very much but he was also very agile the
thing also was he you know worked very
hard at the game you know he in the days
when there was no goalkeeping coaches
and sometimes a goalkeeper would have to
go stay behind for five minutes after
training or ten minutes and get some
lads to stay with them just to do a bit
of shooting and crossing Gordon used to
go back to seen Thursday afternoons and
do extra training so that was his
dedication and and that obviously
enabled him to make the sort of saves
that you know he made against Pele
because of all that hard work and and
obviously that's something I admired
about him
interesting what you say about the
changing nature of the role of the
goalkeeper that it was more physical
then sorry I didn't hear that
you made that you made the point Peter
that it was more physical there were
more heavy challenges from the centre
forward XS yeah
well the the rules are different you're
allowed to go around the penalty box
bouncing the ball and but obviously
there was the physical challenges were
more you know strikers would would you
know which alleys keepers a lot more and
but he's still the same same job keep
the ball out the net and you know the
golfers see the goalkeepers didn't after
sorted to do this playing with the feet
as much at all really and I say it was a
different era but
at that time it was a great era as well
there's a lot of characters in the game
and but Gordon right through his career
you know I took over from him from
England you know I was I took over when
I was 17 at Leicester when Lester sold
him to stoke I went to Stoke a lot of
people thought I took over from Gordon
but I didn't I took over from another
goal Cooper called John for mood who'd
taken over from Gordon previously and
Gordon was that's a youth team coach
the thing about Gordon was he was always
such a nice fella you know he could he
could lose his temper occasionally but
he was he had a great sense of humor and
he was just a real gentleman really and
presumably that carried on even with
that World Cup win under his belt
because I mean if anything could change
if anything could swell the head it
would have been that wouldn't it yes of
course I mean you know to to be part of
a World Cup winning team and all those
players that you know it was in England
everything was in their favor really but
you've still got to go and win the
tournament and obviously the famous game
against West Germany but you know I
think to be a well-cooked winner at that
time was you know made everybody a hero
and you know not by often a goalkeepers
remembered for saves it's obviously when
something goes wrong in games but Gordon
so against Pele obviously was what
really you know highlighted him as you
know as a world-class goalkeeper and
excited I think you know it wasn't by
accident he made that save it was a lot
of hard work that he put in before that
side do we obsess a little bit about
that one particular save to the point
where we forget about all the other work
that he did well of course you know I
mean he yeah you know he had a a great
career at least so we got to I think it
was a couple of FA Cup finals they were
less lost both of them you know and I
think they they won a league but when he
went to Stoke and of course you know he
was always a great goalkeeper whichever
club be playful really and you know
that's why he got in England team and
and I actually took over from him
because he he had an accident car
accident and an injured his eye in a
knee
he really couldn't play again I think
later on he went and played it a little
bit in America but so when that sort of
took off a little bit but he was
basically finished and and it was a bit
cuts his career a little bit short at
the time because you know he still had
quite a few years in front of him I felt